claude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france or votre
rue gassion re réaction pardon vous
également la prise de parole des manuels
macron ce discours était aussi tourné en
faveur du multilatéralisme est ce que
vous y avez vu une pique envers les
états unis
oui bien sûr c'est une pique envers les
je crois que pour poursuivre ce que vic
flick un être dit sur votre avec vos
intervenants
je pense qu'on peut dire que la france a
pu utiliser et peut encore utiliser
l'organisation des nations unies comme
un moyen de relais de relayer son
influence et elle l'a souvent fait
notamment avec des pays qui votait dans
le même sens qu'elle alors souvent on a
un petit peu critiqué le fait qu'un
certain nombre de pays d'afrique de
l'ouest avaient pour habitude de voter
avec la france mais c'est vrai que la
france a des relais d' influence à
travers l'organisation des nations unies
par ailleurs évidemment comme ça vient
d'être dit elle est l'un des cinq
membres permanents
c'était la construction de 1945 il n'y
aurait pas eu d'eau nu si on n'avait pas
donné le droit de veto à certaines
puissances et notamment au vainqueur de
la deuxième guerre mondiale
aujourd'hui ça pose un problème de
gouvernance générale puisque
effectivement d'autres pays sont devenus
puissants doivent exercer toutes leurs
responsabilités politiques au regard de
leur puissance économique et que ces
pays ne sont pas membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité
donc ça c'est le problème permanent et
d'ailleurs la plupart des membres
permanents se plaisent à répéter à des
pays de ce genre de ce que je viens de
citer comme par exemple le japon comme
par exemple l'inde que bien entendu et
il devrait être membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité
sachant pertinemment que cela ne se fera
pas en tout cas pas de sitôt par ce qui
est toujours un des membres permanents
qui a intérêt à s'y opposer
dans le cas des pays asiatiques la chine
n'a évidemment aucun nom aucune envie de
voir un autre pays asiatique devenir
membre permanent
alors le fait que les états unis
et critiquer le raid le multilatéralisme
en effet est très préoccupant pour la
france parce que ce multilatéralisme et
peut être constituer un relais
d'influencé pour un pays qui est
aujourd'hui une puissance moyenne